hundreds of thousands of people took
part in the March for science
[Applause]
they brought microscopes huge crowds
gathered to protest the Trump
administration's anti science positions
on climate change on pollution fracking
and so on and so on
well ladies and gentlemen believe it or
not there were many anti science
protesters there and they were heckling
the science marchers that's how crazy
things have gotten
I was curious who's an anti science
protestor so we invited a few to our
studio tonight ladies and gentlemen here
they are the anti science protesters who
showed up on Saturday first there was
there was this 17th century Puritan
right here then there was this
middle-earth wizard yeah there was this
physics and fortune teller right here
there were unevolved Apes there there
was greg nye bill nye the science guys
jealous brother
Wow what a dick fine there was this kid
there were kids who had science reports
due today and they just didn't want to
do them
what's his name Greg Nye is that it
Greg Nye the he's just an he's very
jealous of his brother I'm gonna tell
him who's on the show tonight let's see
what he thinks of our guests I think we
had a pretty good lineup for example
from the HBO series Silicon Valley
Kumail Nanjiani is on the show
okay just just do your show so brick
sorry this gentleman has been in the
news a lot lately he'll have much to
tell us from the House Intelligence
Committee congressman Adam Schiff is on
the show come on Greg musical guest real
estate gonna perform
okay Greg's a kinks van all right I got
a lot more show coming up we'll take a
break we'll be right back Jimmy take it
away
you